so this particular individual was found
with a sharp iron object embedded into
the lumbar spine
it was a gruesome end to this young
man's life
now one and a half thousand years later
his remains are among hundreds of items
discovered at a major anglo-saxon burial
site unfortunately we can't let our
imaginations run our wild we have to try
and keep as open mind as possible what
we can tell is that this blade was left
in the individual when they died so it's
very possible that it was a cause of
death also
we have the blade mark within this is
the second lumbar vertebrae which is the
bottom of the spine
the skeleton was discovered under a
stretch of the hs2 railway construction
site in wendover
other finds include brooches buckles
glass and spears
there have been hundreds of thousands of
artifacts uncovered so far the eventual
ambition is that they will find their
way into local museums along the hs2
route while hs2 causes some controversy
above ground below it is proving a
treasure trove of britain's history so
hs2 is a fantastic archaeological
opportunity to excavate
areas of the country that wouldn't
necessarily otherwise be developed it's
a series of digs
put together along the route and it's
across a variety of different landscapes
as well so we're we're starting to get a
good picture of those landscapes all the
way from you know deepest pre-history
through the roman period um through to
the saxon period and through into the
medieval period as well
this is one of the largest anglo-saxon
burial sites ever found in britain
a discovery that experts say is of
national significance
dan whitehead sky news